[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Brett is
in Providence Road Island hi Brett
welcome to the Ramy
show hi hi how can we
help um so I we are moving um and we're
selling the house and we're making a
profit on it and um recently I have been
seeing your show on like uh little clips
and I've been changing my mindset of
maybe you know having leas vehicles
isn't the best and smartest uh decision
I've ever made and uh also though
there's we have a plan to use a good
portion of the money uh from selling the
house to use as a down payment uh after
a year of us renting because we don't
know the area we're moving down to
Orlando so we're trying to get a you
know it didn't feel right fight unseen
just to purchase a house typee thing so
we're like we'll rent there get a f for
the area you know know where where we
want to be schoolwise that sounds
wise um so how much is how much you
going to get out of the house what's
going to be the cash in your hand I'm
guessing anywhere between 50 and 60,000
okay and what's it take to pay off your
cars um to pay off we wouldn't be able
to pay off both of them if uh so I have
you you owe more than $60,000 on your
cars um well their leases so I know but
they they have payoff they have an early
buyout provision if you call and ask for
the early buyout have you done that
yet uh yeah so I know the early buyout
for my truck is
49 and uh the other vehicle is probably
around I would guess around like 40 or
so wow you're deep in some cars
dude
yeah uh what is the uh what's your
household
income um I do 180 a year okay all right
well A good rule of thumb if you want to
build wealth is to not have more than
half your annual income tied up in
things with motors and wheels you are
right on that
bubble okay um you're not over it but
you got a lot of car debt
um and you ain't got much home equity
which is kind of weird with income how
long you been making that kind of
money um I've been making uh I made 160
last year yeah um so you know a little
bit of bump um I've only been making
this money since like about I would say
2021 okay just a few years that makes
sense okay and how old are you I mean we
bought this house I'm 35 okay yeah I
bought this house with a VA loan so we
did no money down I can tell yeah yeah
okay and uh purchased the house and in
two years somehow we're selling it um
for a profit which is just craziness but
I love I love Vehicles I'm a car nut um
mathematically uh as a financial person
I hate them because they're the largest
thing that we all buy that goes down in
value and they go down in value rapidly
and so you you've got a lot of money
tied up in um things that go down in
value uh and so here's what I would do
if I woke up in your shoes um I would
sell some of these vehicles if not both
one of them if not both of them and move
down in vehicle to have less money tied
up in things going the wrong way so that
I can put more money into something
that's going up in value which is the
purchase of your home uh so I I would
pay off one and sell one and get you an
inexpensive car to drive and pile up
cash during this year for your down
payment uh if I if I were in your shoes
uh if do you have any money saved
Brett um no um because obviously with
moving in expenses um our savings has
been burn burned paying for you know
transportation of one of the vehicles
because we're driving but we can't drive
both vehicles and you know paying for a
pod to transport uh all of that but
still you're making almost $200,000 a
year and you had no money you just had
10 15,000 bucks to make the move was all
and you burned it so you've got to get
some money back in your hands because
you put it all into vehicles and so uh I
want you to make1 175 $200,000 a year
and have some
money uh not be broke and and that's
what I if I were if that's what I would
like for you you know I love you I want
you to win and that's what I want for
you so if I were in your shoes as much
as I love a nice truck and I've got a
I've got a Ford Raptor that is an
absolute Beast it's amazing vehicle I
love cars um and and so but but I'm not
going to love them so much that they eat
me alive and they yours are eating you
up man because it's 90 grand and yeah
you got $90,000 tied up and your house
had nothing down and you barely had
enough cash to move and this and you
make a lot of money so I want to make a
lot of money and have some and and not
be feeding these beasts so um I'm
probably selling the expensive one
paying off the inexpensive one getting a
a a very inexpensive cash car down in
Orlando and so in Orlando you don't have
to even transport them yeah probably too
late they're probably already moved but
the uh but either way and just be be
free of all this because if you're
sitting there with no car payments and
you're renting you can stack some
serious cash for your down payment now
yep
and um and then draw a line in the Santa
says I pay cash for things from now on
yeah and don't be afraid to rent for two
years if you guys have to to because you
felt the pain of putting nothing down
and not having a lot of equity so even
if you guys kind of slow pace it into
that move that's okay too but if you got
no payments in the world and you make
200 stack a
hundred I mean live I mean oh darn I
have to live on H 100,000 in Orlando I
don't know if I can do that or not of
course you can people do it every day so
I mean yeah stack a hundred in a year
you know uh and that's a pretty strong
downstroke for a house that put you in a
good place or wait two years and stack
200 yeah that'd be pretty neat this is
the kind of thing you can do when you're
not giving it all to the car company in
the form of a fleece so Brett you'd
already come to these conclusions but I
probably took you uh about four notches
along the radical steps uh you know took
you a little bit more radical than you
wanted to go when you called in be
careful what you wish for when you call
the show boys and girls but um that's
what I would do man just just because
here's the thing for a long time I drove
cars I really hated cuz they were
crappy and they were
hoopties and I drove like no one else so
that later I can drive anything I
freaking want
to you live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else a and so you you pay a price to win
you sacrifice to get yourself in a
position because making that kind of
money dude in five or six years you
could be a millionaire if you watch what
you're doing yeah absolutely okay so
talk through because we we always say
and it's been proven that leasing is the
most expensive way to finance a vehicle
so talk through the lease aspect of it
just from like the the number standpoint
of basically renting before you have to
buy it out when you finance a vehicle
the federal truth and lending laws the
regulations require them to hand you a
sheet that shows you what your APR is
the interest rate they're ripping you
off with okay when you lease a vehicle
you don't own
it so you're not technically borrowing
money under the law so they do not have
to disclose the interest that they are
charging you but there is an interest
calculation because you can take the
actual cost of the car versus the stream
of payments called your lease payments
versus the the price at the closed in
lease at the back end these are three
three or four Financial variables I can
put them in my financial calculator and
back into what your interest rate is
it's called the capitalization rate
because it's not technically interest
but as we've done that in this industry
now we found that the typical car lease
in America is being capitalized at
14.2% so you're borrowing money at
subprime
rates when you lease a car but people
people that lease cars and I'm not
picking on Brett cuz he's come to the
conclusion that this doesn't work but
you know to answer your question F this
is not AED at Brett this is just talking
about the subject right Brett thank you
for calling we appreciate you when you
lease a car you're not asking what the
interest rate is you're the people that
ask how much down and how much a month
what's the least amount per month and
the least amount down and I can drive
this
car rich people ask how much poor people
and broke people ask how much down and
how much a month and that's what drives
you into the lease the lease is the most
expensive thing on the car lot that's
why the car companies push them so hard
because they make more money on those
than they do on the stinking car